ladies and gentlemen if you're listening
on audio this is going to be a bit of an
asmr experience for you what we have set
up today is a one-of-one lie detector
test most lie detector tests it's just
like a little needle you know drawing on
a piece of paper like oh i'm lying not
today we actually have a replica matthew
mcconaughey foot and boot and if cody
tells a lie today it's going to kick him
right in the balls
this is ridiculous why but there's no
reason for me to be scared are you sure
yes
this doesn't look that like intimidating
at all
i tell the truth i don't lie so i don't
need to be scared so now let's just get
a baseline test okay cool yeah not
scared
is your name cody
yes my first name yes yes do you have a
youtube channel yes i do you like food
a bit too much sometimes
okay all right what's your favorite food
mashed
potatoes see
okay that was my old answer now i
usually say chicken and waffles
everything yeah
no no no no no they're both real they're
both true i don't know i mean on this
podcast you know you for the bibimbap
so it's getting a bit of a reading
that's number three yeah that's my
favorite
hello fresh meal okay oh you should try
the bibimbap
it didn't react
okay you have a favorite football team
yes
are you sure i want to get a bit of a
reading here
okay well i don't really watch football
that often but i do love the detroit
lions
did not like that it did not like that
i'm [ __ ] my pants right now dude i'm
[ __ ] my pants it did not like i'm
trying my best these questions are kind
of abstract yeah they're not just yes or
no's it's like you know it's you know
it's you know well this is a more
advanced lie detecting machine but we
can go with some yes or nos yeah do you
think euphoria is a good show no okay
all right now we're good i mean last
episode was pretty good yeah oh hey no
okay yeah that was good all right all
right nailed it i'm passing with flying
colors right now
does this thing even work
yeah oh okay um how about this
are you friends and business partners
with jericho
[Music]
well i'm going to be oh oh
yeah did not like that
it did not like it
out
hit it again
i've been working out every single day
oh i'm really about my fitness right now
oh yeah oh
okay all right yeah keep going get
another one
wow
[Laughter]